- [Instructor] A disk is
initially rotating clockwise
around a fixed axis with
angular speed omega nought.
At time t equals zero,
the two forces of F sub
one is equal to 20 newtons
and F sub two is equal to 10
newtons are exerted on the disk
as shown in the figure below.
So these are the magnitudes,
but here they show the
magnitude and the direction.
And they say, which graph
could show the angular velocity
of the disk over time?
So before I even show you the options,
let's see if we can just
sketch it ourselves.
So pause this video
and see if you can sketch
the angular velocity
of the disk over time.
All right, so in our vertical axis here,
let's put our angular velocity.
And then in our horizontal axis here,
we wanna see how that changes over time.
So what is our initial angular velocity?
Well, they tell us that our
angular speed is omega nought
and the direction is in
the clockwise direction.
They tell it right over there.
And the typical convention
is that clockwise,
clockwise is negative
and counterclockwise would be positive.
So we're starting at a
negative angular velocity.
Let's see right over there.
And it actually would be
negative omega nought.
I'll just write negative omega nought.
Remember, omega nought is
the speed, the angular speed,
so it's the magnitude
of the angular velocity.
But since we're going
clockwise, it would be negative,
so we're gonna start right there.
And now let's see what the net torque is.
F one, we're assuming, goes straight down
and it's perpendicular to the radius.
Let's call that r, that length r.
And F two is straight down.
It's perpendicular to the radius.
But F one is providing a torque
in the counterclockwise direction,
while F two is providing a torque
in the clockwise direction.
And the way it's
depicted, F one is larger,
and they're both r away
from the center of rotation.
So your net torque is going
to be counterclockwise.
It's going to be against the direction
or the starting direction of rotation.
If your net torque is counterclockwise.
So we could say our net torque
is going to be positive.
Positive.
And if our net torque is positive,
that means that our angular acceleration
is going to be positive.
And our angular acceleration
is just the rate of change
of our angular velocity.
And this is going to be constant,
assuming that these forces are constant.
You're going to see this.
We're going to be rotating clockwise
at a slower and slower rate
until all of a sudden the
wheel switches direction
or the disk switches directions
and then all of a sudden we
are rotating counterclockwise.
So it would look something like that.
So let's see which of these choices fit.
So if we look at all of 'em,
this looks almost exactly like we drew,
but let's just review what
these other ones are saying.
This one is implying here
that you're starting off going clockwise,
but then you're accelerating
in the clockwise direction.
And that wasn't the direction
that the net torque was being applied in,
so we rule that out.
This assumes that you're starting
in the counterclockwise direction,
which we know is not the case.
This assumes that you're starting
in the counterclockwise direction.
And then you're accelerating
in the clockwise direction.
And you would've picked this
if you got your convention mixed up
between counterclockwise and clockwise
and which one is positive or negative,
but we can rule that one
out, and the choice is A.